este restaurante de kiev los comensales
se han acostumbrado a comer a la luz de
las velas se han introducido cortes de
energía programados en la capital de
Ucrania ya que Rusia ha apuntado
repetidamente a la red eléctrica de la
nación
creo que la energía se va a cuatro veces
por semana
y cada vez dura cuatro horas
los recientes ataques con drones han
destruido el 30% de las centrales
eléctricas de Ucrania en una semana
mientras las autoridades instan a sus
ciudadanos a reducir drásticamente el
consumo
a partir de este momento muchas ciudades
y regiones de nuestro país utilizan
horarios de bloqueo de estabilización
casi 4 millones de ucranianos se
enfrentan actualmente a estas
restricciones la mayoría de las ciudades
importantes se han visto obligadas a
implementar medidas de ahorro de
Electricidad sin precedentes que se
reparten con el uso de los trenes para
quitar presión a la red en harkif las
calles se sumergen en la oscuridad todos
los días con intervalos el tiempo frente
a las pocas opciones los residentes
recurren a bancos de energía para
mantenerse conectados pero no es
suficiente después de que se corta la
electricidad aproximadamente una hora u
hora y media más tarde toda la red
telefónica está cortada tampoco tenemos
internet en nuestros teléfonos
los proveedores privados de electricidad
en el beef y cherniffy han reducido
horarios para limitar el consumo de
Electricidad de las Industrias pero
mientras tanto las alertas de bombas
suenan casi todo el tiempo además de la
gran escasez de personal que a menudo no
permite la reparaciones de las centrales
eléctricas
el equipo dañado es único es difícil de
encontrar repuestos y la producción de
nuevos toma mucho tiempo
con el invierno acercándose rápidamente
se está acabando el tiempo para
asegurarse de que las luces permanezcan
encendidas en Ucrania